welcome back to the 50th ever episode of
the iced coffee hour
my name is ryan pineda and we've made
approximately 55
818 dollars that was really good that
was fantastic
great job brian great it's almost like
i've done this before yeah yeah it was
only like the fifth try too
speaking of which you are on episode 24
the 24th ever episode of the iced coffee
hour
coming back on the 50th ever episode of
the iced coffee hour
yeah i'm happy to have you back on dude
i'm excited you guys invited me again
man
we got to talk about real estates
because i feel like when it comes to
especially las vegas market
you're the one who i would really look
to for advice on what's going on with
the real estate market here
what you're seeing in terms of pricing
real estate trends
rental prices how to make money how do
you even buy something in this market
and jack he's talking my year off now
about trying to buy his first property
so i think
this would be a great introduction to
teach anybody how to buy their first
rental property how to even get their
first property to begin with in such a
competitive market with interest rates
so low
you're our guy uh well i'm glad you guys
invited me and jack
you know jack was at my office what was
that a couple weeks ago two weeks ago
and he was like man
can you help me get my first rental
property or my first property in general
and i think that was the only reason you
invited me back you just no
no no you wanted advice but he didn't
want to pay you for it i know
yeah you know this is fine so um yeah
man it's
it's crazy right now the market and if
you're just getting started trying to
buy your first house like
it's never been harder and that's the
tough part about it is
there's no inventory like literally
anywhere you know everything's a bidding
war
and you're gonna pay you know top dollar
right now
and i think in a lot of places rents
haven't caught up to the appreciation
you know typically
rents are gonna lag from the pricing so
we're experiencing
so much appreciation and rents like
haven't caught up yet so it's like tough
to pencil the numbers in as a rental
unless you're in like a midwest market
or you're
putting a lot of money down on the house
and trying to get your payment lower
so it's it's much more difficult today
than ever before
i'll say that what year did you start
buying real estate
i bought my first house back in 2011. i
was ah same year same year as me
didn't meant to be yeah so i was 22 at
the time right around your age too it's
21.
and um yeah i bought it with an fha loan
which i highly recommend people do if
they're just starting like low down
payment is possible
and dude i bought it for 160 grand
literally like five minutes from here
and if you can imagine for 165 minutes
from here
and uh it's worth probably about four to
five hundred now wow
yep are you renting it right now no i
sold it i sold it like two years later
yeah
and what do you do did you just use that
profit to buy another yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah i had to keep turning my money
over and over to continue to build up
you know if if i ever kept a rental i
wouldn't have been able to live
the only way i made money was by
flipping houses and just continuing that
was my income
got it what'd you end up selling it for
i sold it two years later for
220 like right around there um we put a
little bit of money into it not a lot
but
and and even then it wasn't even like i
got a great deal
it was just appreciation had happened so
i think that was cool i ended up rolling
that profit
into my next house which i bought for
what did i buy that one for
170 and i sold that one two years later
for 240
you know kind of the same deal again
appreciation and
i've kind of just every two years go
have gone to a new primary because
you know you get tax-free capital gains
and
you know luckily my income was
increasing and you know i got a family
now so we had to keep getting a bigger
home so
yeah that's kind of how i got started
and i think it's a great way for
other people to get started is you know
buying a personal residence just
with an fha loan do you oh do you keep
rentals now
yeah how many i've got over 30.
how do you do it i i am like
in awe at the schedules of some people
that we've had on the podcast like
between your schedule
meet kevin's schedule it blows my mind
how you can get so much done
30 rental properties yeah yeah we
probably have
i i have about 10 units in big bear
california
that we airbnb and then we have
a 10 unit apartment here in vegas which
i've done a youtube video on
super cool how we bought that um with
seller financing
i got a 300 000 apartment
with 16 000 down and no payments for
three years
it was a crazy deal and then the other
10 um
rentals are like single families or
condos here in vegas
who would do that deal on the seller a
thousand dollars down
no payments on three years who would do
that so i'll give you the
five minute story of how it happens so
we
are cold calling sellers and stuff
trying to get marketing
or trying to find deals this seller
picks up he's like hey
i don't want to sell this house i have
but i own this 10 unit apartment
and at the time this was three years ago
i didn't know anything about apartment
investing
and all that and i go we'll buy an
apartment like you know like
if if the deal's right we'll figure it
out so we go there it's in a really
rough part of town here in vegas
kind of where we were last night and um
he's like hey
uh you know i haven't gotten rent in
three years
and i said okay that's not good but it's
also a sign of motivation
and so we go there and we see it's just
like
really bad i mean gang banging like
selling guns and stuff like legit and
we also noticed that one of the units
burned down like he didn't even know
and he didn't know that one of the units
no he had no idea how bad was it was it
burned
like it was crisp it was done done
everything inside burnt to a crisp i
have it i'll show you a picture after
so wow i end up calling them i'm like
hey man
this is a bad situation like did you
know that a unit's burned down he's like
what
couldn't believe it out of state owner
in california and um
you know we just start talking and
negotiating and
at the time i still didn't really know
what it was worth i was also like hey
i can't even get in the units i don't
know how much renovation it needs like
i have to get it for a crazy deal so i
end up just offering 200 grand i'm like
i'll give you 200 grand whatever
he's like no i want 400. and after like
a month or two of negotiating
we finally agreed on 300 but he was
gonna sell or finance it
and basically my pitch was look you know
it's going to cost me a lot of money to
fix this it's going to cost me a lot of
time to get all these tenants out
and you know i have no idea the
condition
and so he agreed and basically we we
came to the conclusion that
it was going to be beneficial for both
of us to not have payments for
the next three years because he hadn't
begun payments for three years already
so it's not like anything's different
and in fact he was behind on his taxes
because of that he hadn't paid property
taxes
so i paid off all his property taxes he
owed it was 16 grand
that was where it came from and he ended
up
giving me three years to basically you
know revitalize the place
so it took me about seven eight months
to get
all the tenants out because what would
happen is we'd evict one
and they would move into another unit
and how
they would squat yep then there's
nothing like i mean obviously it's not
right but
you it sucks so bad that you have to
start the whole eviction process on that
unit
because you know you evict somebody from
school even if they squat
yeah how is that legal for a squatter
who's to stop
who's to not like come into one of my
properties just overnight and be like
yeah i live here here's a least
agreement couldn't i feel like that you
just call the cops kick them out
i mean there are situations like on our
flips they're all vacant right so if
somebody breaks in
we do do that but these people did live
there in that apartment for
you know however long they did like they
did have a right to live there but not
that unit
not that are there any like legal
repercussions on their end for doing
that
i mean they got nothing to lose like it
just didn't they didn't care
but long story short like we had to keep
kicking these people out
and finally after like you know seven
eight months we finally got everyone out
and we started
renovating it because we didn't want to
renovate a unit and then have somebody
move into it
uh that's not supposed to be there so we
wanted to get everyone out first
so it wasn't making money for at least a
year which is why i was like
we need time i'm not paying you you know
because i got to do all the work that
you didn't do
but we ended up spending about 200 grand
getting it fixed up it makes 7
000 a month now and gross um i'm going
to make my first payment
this july for 12.50
gosh how does this guy go three years
though without receiving
any rent graham dude you would you would
be surprised
at how many sellers just don't care
no i'm serious like they we talk to
sellers every day we buy homes every
you know week like there's so many
sellers that just
neglect a property for years like it's
vacant for years they never even try to
rent it or
you know it's it's beat up and if they
just put some money into it it would be
rentable but they don't want to do it
they just
have no desire maybe they inherited the
property it just they don't care
do they just have so much money it's
just not worth their time is that it
yeah i think a lot of sellers if they
have rentals like this
yeah especially if they have apartments
and stuff you know that they're somewhat
sophisticated
um but you know on the single family
side
you you just dude you'd be surprised at
the things you see
on the in the off market world because
you don't see it like on the realtor
side where
you know they're they go get a realtor
they list their like that's
the standard stuff but off market is
where
you see like the realness of real estate
and what's going on
on the single family side i mean in
everything
and everything jack is interested in the
single family that kind of piques my
interest
yeah are you finding off market deals
right now but first i want to thank our
sponsor policy genius april can be an
extremely busy month for all of us
whether you're getting your taxes done
spring cleaning around the house or
getting fooled by graham saying he's
moving back to california policy genius
recognizes that april can be a difficult
month so they're here to make your april
a little bit better by providing fast
and free insurance quotes policy genius
can help you find insurance similar to
what you have right now but at a better
rate and that's just free money that you
could save just by switching policy
genius saves their customers up to a
thousand and fifty five dollars a year
when they reshop for home and auto
coverage and getting started could never
be easier just head to policygenius.com
and answer a few questions about you and
your property then policy genius takes
it from there by comparing the rates
from top insurance providers such as
allstate and progressive to help you
find the lowest rate and best coverage
they will even compare ways to bundle
your insurance such as home and auto to
save you even more money and if they
find you a lower rate than what you have
right now they will switch you over for
free
policy genius can promise you that you
will not leave their website feeling
like a fool and take it from me i've
used it before and it's a great service
head to policygenius.com to get started
now policy genius when it comes to
insurance it's nice to get it right
that is where we find 90 of our deals at
the moment
okay yeah because when i first got my
start you know i i was a realtor just
like you i got licensed in 2010
and i didn't start flipping houses until
2015. back in 2010
you know inventory was so high dude
there was like pick your pick whatever
you want it's
pick of the litter and buyers were just
they had all the control because there's
so much supply
2015 things like stabilized i still
found a lot of deals on the mls and
you know for me when i find a deal like
it's got to be at least
80 of value like that's the max i'm
willing to pay
and you know around 17 18 the market
starts to get less inventory 18 there
was really low inventory
and now we're at the point where it's
like the lowest inventory in history
right and so you your strategy has to
change
based on the market you know back in
2010 if i was a buyer
i'd be offering people 50 cents on the
dollar because it's just there's so much
available
today if you go on market you have to
offer above list
and prices just keep going up and so if
you're going to succeed in my shoes like
as a flipper or
even if i want to buy buy and holds i
can't just
overpay and build a portfolio doesn't
work
so we go off market now and 90 of our
deals are off market
how do you do that walk us through the
process so there's a lot of ways to get
off market deals
um one way the easiest way for anyone
watching
is just buying them from wholesalers so
wholesalers are people that lock up
deals
off market they market up you know a
little bit of money
and uh they sell it to an in buyer and
the wholesaler doesn't ever actually buy
the home they just sell the contract
okay we wholesale as well we buy from
wholesalers i've bought a lot of houses
from wholesalers they're great because
they do all the work for you you know
jack if let's just say
my company home run offer found you a
deal or we found a deal
and it was discounted right because we
got it off market and we still made our
spread and i was like jack
you can't find a house like this on the
market but i'm gonna sell it to you for
you know 85 cents on the dollar would
you want it yes
how did you do that yeah we do it every
day
that's why i'm saying like a
wholesaler's the easiest way because
they're doing all the work for you you
just have to have the capital ready to
buy it
that's what it comes down to so i think
that's like the easiest step for people
just getting started
but if you want to really like find off
market deals you got to start marketing
yourself
and so you know realtors what kind of
marketing did you do as realtor graham
craigslist okay so craigslist is a great
way to prospect
um but really like the main ways people
prospect starting out
just i'll name five cold calling text
messaging
door knocking um people can do
those are like the three cheapest ways
driving for dollars people always talk
about as well
and then if you want to get more
expensive you can do direct mail we run
tv commercials here in vegas
um you can do ppc so you just rank at
the top of search
we know that for youtube right do the
same thing for you know if people search
sell my house cash sell my house now
you'll pop up right
so you have the cheap ways of doing it
which i would
assume many people here want to do which
is great and then you have
more expensive ways we do a combination
of both so we spend
currently about 50 to 60 grand a month
on all those methods to find off-market
deals
yeah you're doing everything i hated
doing as an agent well but i don't do it
you don't do it right i did all of that
though i couldn't stand it
yeah yeah i did door knocking for like
two weeks straight
and i at the end of the two weeks i
wanted to quit i was like
i can't do this anymore if otherwise i'm
gonna quit real estate right i hated it
that much
same with cold calling did it work for
you
uh door knocking i met a few cool people
uh a few of them i came back again took
pictures but
they all wanted prices that were so high
they're like okay i don't really want to
sell but if you bring me an offer at
two and a half million then i'll sell
the places may be worth like two
right you know so that's who i met yeah
and
the thing is i just named all the ways
you can do it i mean you only have to be
really good at one of them
it's not like you're the one having to
cold call every time like if you don't
like it
it's it's not a big deal so it's just
really figuring out what i always teach
our students is
first look at your budget okay your
budget's going to determine how you
market first and foremost secondly once
you have your budget
then you can start figuring out the
marketing channel but the third thing is
figuring out
after that basically your sales process
because so many people
think that oh if i spend money on
marketing i make money like it's just
i'm going to get an roi i was like no if
you can't close deals
then you will not get an roi you'll
waste money
and so um i think if you're a beginner
and you are like if you want to go spend
money well let's talk about the freeways
so if you don't have any money at all
and you want to go find deals okay
best way is door knocking okay there's a
lot of
houses that are distressed you can go
knock on beat up houses that you see in
the neighborhood
you can um go uh get a list of like
properties that have motivation for free
so back
before you know the pandemic and people
had foreclosures
you could go get the foreclosure list
and start door knocking them and
trying to buy their house before it gets
foreclosed on and that's a good strategy
because
obviously they need to sell or they're
going to get foreclosed on
and they don't have time to list with a
realtor because
it's too close so if you knock those you
have a very high chance of getting a
deal
and it's free it's free to go door knock
but if you have a little bit of money
i would say call it less than like 3 000
a month if you're willing to spend less
than 3 000 a month
you can get a good list you can cold
call it since you have that list of
numbers you might as well text it as
well
and there's softwares that allow you to
do that very easy all from the same spot
it's not like you're
hand dialing and hand texting i get
those texts probably once a week
yep yeah they're from me so you were
telling me that you're actually
in a lawsuit right now with these with
these calls right
yeah so you guys you had told me before
we started filming that you had a
you know one of these robo-dialer
lawyers one of the top
lawyers who fights that yeah so
basically there are people who are now
like i mean they have facebook groups
and stuff
um dedicated to trying to like
essentially extort
marketers you know they're like oh you
know
for instance every time you get that
text if you like tried to really go
after them
i mean you could try and hire your guy
that you just had and
you know you could try to sue them or at
least send them a letter trying to
extort them like that's
what's going on today um but
for instance like we're talking about
this lawsuit and i can't talk in detail
about it but
i guess one thing is in real estate if
you do enough deals you're going to get
lawsuits no matter what that's just life
but two like this guy he's trying to
claim that we called him like
200 times like we did not call you 200
times
it's not even like realistic but his
whole thing is like well each offense is
like a thousand bucks so
i want two hundred thousand dollars
we're like you're out of your mind
and essentially he's either trying to
lump us all into the same thing you're
like oh ryan must have text me every
week this it's like
it was probably a bunch of different
people you know doing it
um but that's just kind of like what
these guys do now
and uh you can kind of tell because
for and this is good feedback for those
of you who are gonna cold call to kind
of help prevent future lawsuits
they're going to be phishing you know
trying to get information
okay who's your company what's your last
name all this what's your website like
and then that way they're like all right
he called me on this day blah blah blah
you owe me 1500 bucks but couldn't it be
something as simple don't they have to
tell you first
take me off the list there so they have
do not call list
they have um other lists as well like so
there's so much gray area right now with
marketing
you know because with the robo dialing
thing there's some things that are legal
there are some that's not
but they're kind of like the same thing
you know and it's it's almost impossible
to prove which
method somebody was using um same thing
with text messaging
right now they're changing text
messaging laws that you have to have an
opt-out in the text and so um text
messaging used to be really good for us
because we could send out you know a
million text and
you know you get the leads and all that
stuff but
after um now people can just opt out
and so once they opt out you have to
take them off your list and so
the software won't even allow you to
text them anymore
um so the laws are always changing
and um even too so think about this when
you are a realtor
it's actually really strict for realtors
because
you're not allowed to solicit like that
so like you as a realtor you're like hey
i want to list your house like can i
list your house and get an appointment
that's a solicitation
but me as the cash buyer when i say
graham i want to buy your house i'm not
soliciting i'm not trying to sell you
anything
i just want to buy your house so it's
different it's legal
yeah so like one thing we'll tell our
realtors too because i own a brokerage
as well
is hey if you are going to cold call and
do this stuff to protect yourself to
protect the brokerage
um you just got to say hey i've got a
cash buyer who wants to buy your house
because they really do my agents have me
i will buy their house if
we can get it for the right price right
so yeah even technically a dollar
yeah hey if i could buy for a dollar
pocket i'll buy your app that makes it
legal
even if you have a dollar well yeah i
mean
for the realtors they're saying i have a
cash buyer ready to buy your house i
mean
i will buy it you know it's not mr beast
have you seen this video or you gave
away the houses for a dollar yeah
that was cool but um no i mean
it that's what it is like you you
personally don't have to have the money
i mean it's like
as long as you're just being transparent
about what it is you want
that's where i think is the best
practice like
for us it's like i just want to buy your
house dude like just tell me yes or no
yeah
so if i'm looking to buy my first
like home here in las vegas first off
graham says he thinks i should rent
yep i think i should buy do you have any
input on that now
first of all he's got to hear the
arguments yeah yeah i want to hear why
you think rent
okay this would be jack's first place
his first time
really living on his own outside of of
his parents
and uh i think given jack's
income the money he's going to be making
five years from now is going to be
completely different than what he's
making today
in a great way so my thinking is this
we just moved to a new state i think
it's better for him
to get situated with renting a spot uh
getting situated with that first really
getting to know the areas where he wants
to live
within about a year and a half he's
gonna have a way
different income profile than what he
has this year
so i think whatever he buys today
is going to be different than what he's
going to want probably three to four
years from now
he's 22 right now he's going to be 25
26.
what the place that he's living now is
going to be way different
than 25 26 what you're going to want
later so i think it's probably better
right now
rent it's a very competitive market get
situated
uh see what you like and what you don't
like and then buy especially if you're
going to be plunking down that money
that is my argument that's why i think
at least for the next 12 to 18 months
jack is better off renting
so jack i am going to disagree with
graham and i agree that you should buy
and here's why
but first i want to thank our sponsor
today landlord go landlord go is a game
where you can buy
or sell properties in your area
virtually here's how it works we're
going to open the app and then we're
gonna click on the travel agent in the
top right corner the travel agent is a
great feature that allows you to go
anywhere in the world to buy properties
while we're in lockdown and i'm gonna
buy this
and also buy this because they're the
same color and by buying properties of
the same color i can get additional
return on my investment now that the
buildings are mine
i can finally collect rent or even
upgrade them to make more money then if
i want i can list these properties in
the marketplace for other people to bid
on them instead of just selling it to
the bank and here is the game
leaderboard and as you can see i'm
ranked
this in the united states and this in
vegas landlord also has this really cool
ar feature where you can go around your
city and search for properties in real
life
all right so we're actually out in the
wild right now and there's a super cuts
right there
i love super cuts and that is exactly
why i think they would be a
perfect property to add to the portfolio
all right so i'm going to be using the
ar feature to buy up the super cuts
you just get in the frame click on the
tile
and then you buy as many as you can i've
just found this game as a really fun
thing to do in my free time and it's
also a great way to familiarize myself
with las vegas so if you want to try the
game for yourself and become a virtual
landlord
click the link in the description and
you will receive free in-game cash and a
special bundle pack that's specific to
the link in the description thank you so
much landlord go for sponsoring this
episode and back to the podcast
um as i said in my story i was 22 when i
bought my first house just like you
um i didn't know where i was gonna live
five years from then
but i did know that you know if i got a
good deal
i i would have no problem selling it two
years from now and getting the capital
gains
you know and all the money that i make
from it so if
you found a good deal today i would
rather you buy it
live in it two years get tax-free
capital gains and then just upgrade buy
another house
but then it's also the maintenance then
it's also maintaining the property and
keeping it in good condition
and then figuring out well are you gonna
sell it two years from now what if
interest rates go up what if the market
goes down
i think back in 2011 2012 when we were
first starting to buy real estate
we had all the edge we had the advantage
and we benefited from
the insane appreciation of buying
something one 160
the next year it's worth 200 grand you
just made a whole bunch of money
right now we are in the most competitive
time ever right
in the history of housing with interest
rates really low by the way so
so that is i think in jack's favor but
we're at a time
where jack is going to be competing with
potentially all cash offers and it i
know you would take good care of jack
i have no question about that but from a
seller's perspective on a broad scale
if they have a cash offer or they have
the potential for a quick close cash
or jack would have to go through
financing i would rather pick the cash
offer
yeah so i think just just the market in
general right now
but you're looking at it from the
perspective of jack is going to pay
market value or above market value where
i'm saying
yeah i don't agree in fact i don't agree
in any market paying market value
that goes against everything i do yeah
what i'm telling jack to do
is if he can find a good deal that's 80
to
85 cents on the dollar even 90 cents on
the dollar if you're gonna live there
um i would rather bet that in two years
you're gonna still get appreciation
things are still gonna be on
my bet is that in two years it will
still be the way it is
maybe not to this level now but it's not
like things are tanking
two years from now your house will not
be worth less than it is today
i can like i mean nobody has a crystal
ball but
and hopefully two years from now is
somebody watching this i don't look
really stupid
but um i would i would be very
surprised if it was worth less my only
argument to that is that
you buying today 90 cents on the dollar
is you buying up
six percent from a year ago you're still
buying higher than a year and that's not
to say that like oh you know prices
you're buying you know higher than a
year that's bad i just think
right now in the current market even
buying at 90 cents on the dollar
is still a high price given the lack of
inventory and the amount of demand right
now that we're seeing in las vegas
well i mean i can tell you this jack for
us
we are every flip we've done
i mean we're getting like 10 more than
we thought like it's insane so like
a house i bought um three months ago
that is now hitting the market today and
we were like okay this is gonna sell for
300.
we're listing it for 330 and getting it
and this is like
in a three month span and there's no
indication that this is going to stop
you know demand is still very high
they're still pumping money into the
economy rates are not going up
like so there's so many factors that say
hey guess what you know you might be
sitting on the waiting game and uh
and it might be hurting you even more a
year from now
um i i just believe that the other part
as well is
getting into your first property also is
going to like
start your process as a real estate
investor like the sooner you start
you know the sooner you start making
moves and like you're just getting in
the game quicker you're learning like
when did you buy your first property
you're 21 21.
like you could have rented at 21 and and
did the same thing but
by starting your journey sooner it's
allowed you to become who you are today
i had a different uh uh schedule though
when i was 21 i had a whole bunch of
free time i had nothing going on on
weekends
uh i will not say nothing going on on a
weekend sunday's obviously open houses
but there was a lot of time
where you know even if i worked 10 hours
as a real estate agent i had all night i
had nothing to do i was trying to fill
my time as much as possible
jack is a unique opportunity where for
him going and finding
one extra sponsor would be the
equivalent of getting
rent on multiple rental properties right
so when i look at the time commitment
i'm like jack spent
five hours a month one extra sponsor
that's like
three rental properties right there yeah
guaranteed to come in
with really no risk at all it's
guaranteed
i see that i'm like from a time
perspective the time is most valuable
spent
so i agree with you there and that's the
reason i got on youtube and started
doing these other things because i
noticed that
i said dang like this is risk-free money
this is
yeah i'm used to taking out millions in
debt to buy real estate
it's a very risky business no matter how
good you are you know the market could
collapse at any moment
you could buy bad deals and you know
really become insolvent
but um i i there's nothing to stop jack
from
devoting all of his time and resources
into you know this
and building up the channel and
everything but there's
like if you just go the route of meeting
wholesalers
and then just letting them do all the
work where you're just literally looking
at the deals and you're like yes or no
you know you're not scavenging the mls
and zillow
i think that could be a happy medium
where you end up finding a good deal
and and what would happen too then is
like if
you if you find that deal you could just
do a burr out of it because you're
getting a good deal
so maybe graham funds it for you you
know because you got to buy all cash or
with a hard money loan
from these wholesalers they're not
waiting for a conventional loan
but um after that you can just refinance
right away
and you know get all the cash out
because you have enough equity
i would fund you i would do that i mean
i want to pretty
much i want to we'll have to talk about
that but i would i would find you on
that what percent
i don't know
[Music]
here's what will happen is we will when
i get a house that i think
is good for jack you know it'll be
discounted
and i will bring it to jack first
because
of everything you guys have done for me
and um we'll still make money on it
obviously but
you're going to get something way more
discounted than what is currently on the
market
and you won't have to have done any work
for it you'll just have to say yeah
i'd live here so you just got to tell me
like your budget
i would that would i mean i love as many
options as i can get and but you would
prefer that
then we look at the uh just the overall
like jack spends 1200 bucks a month on
rent
for a good spot nearby versus spending
it's probably going to be
2829
jack how much of a house are you trying
to buy like what's the price point
graham has an i said under 400 000
that's what graham says
okay yeah i mean i think i think under
five
dang jack all right it's like that's
what i'm saying all right so
jack man all right you're much more of a
baller than i was
that's three thousand dollars a month i
can rent out the rooms though that's my
plan
jack i mean alex said he needs he would
he would rent a room
alex said so you know so i had this
conversation with andre
before he bought his house you know he
ended up buying his house for like 700.
you don't need a house as big as andre's
right now like i would just be like i
agree with graham on that i think you're
under 400 is like really good um
and at under 400 you're what is that you
know
2000 to 2400 a month i'm gonna call it
25 26.
yeah but if you house hack like you said
you get the same result but you you have
a house of your own
and and you're buying discounted i mean
like if if let's just say
you buy this 400 000 house but you get
it for 350
would you would you want to buy that
it's an area you live in absolutely
okay we get that all the time we could
sell you that all day
because we can't flip that at 350 once
we factor in our cost and we resell it
and realtor fees we wouldn't make you
know we might make
10 grand max we're not making 10 grand
on a 400 000 house but
to sell it to you for 350 makes sense
because you're gonna go live in it and
you're not paying the 420
that maybe it gets on the market because
it's so crazy why wouldn't you just take
that house at 350 and
immediately list it and flip it for 400
grand
because like i said you you we don't buy
all our properties with our own cash so
we pay
hard money lenders or private lenders oh
that's where it gets expensive okay
so i mean at 350 let's just say we hold
it for
three months right this has no
renovation like very light
whatever um three months of that is
probably you know close to ten thousand
dollars in fees then you have
the realtor fees call that another like
15 grand you're 25
plus title fees on both sides purchase
and sell you know another
whatever eight grand 10 grand so just if
simple numbers you're at like
45 grand and we're trying to sell for
400
so we won't make money flipping it but
you holding it
you love it because it's just you're
getting 50 grand in equity plus the
upside
i would be so grateful for an
opportunity like that like i'm telling
you if you really want to do it
in a month i like we'll have a house for
you
in a month yeah i mean we got we've
gotten
we're in the middle of april we're
having a really good month we've gotten
13 deals this month let's talk about
financing
because i think we've already talked
about the uh the obstacles of finding a
house
what about financing what are you
finding right now how much money down
how
jack be able to get financed how would
this how would this play out
okay so for those watching the way
you're gonna get financed is by just
getting an fha loan or conventional loan
i always recommend the lowest down
payment just because
it's too hard to save up 20 for most
people like
man to save up 80 grand on a 400 000
house
by the time you save it up that 400 000
house might be worth 500.
so i i think lowest down payment
possible
but in jack's case with how we're
talking about it what i would say is
you know you should fund it make
whatever you make off of it you know
it's cool income for you
jack gets the benefit of getting an off
market deal and then jack refinances
at the real value of the home they're
not gonna they're not gonna appraise it
at the 350 that we sold it to them for
they're gonna appraise it at
the new value what you would do graham
is
you would put a lien against jack's
property for your funding
and at that point it now becomes rate
and term for jack because
he's not getting cash out like he's just
refinancing you out you're the bank
you're the debt and um
they can give you the new value based on
that
if jack had four hundred thousand and he
put it four hundred thousand down
well now he's cash out refi and cash out
refi
has lower loan to value ratios higher
interest rates
um so it it benefits
this plan that we're talking about is
like the best way to do it
it'd be funny if i just bought the
property rented to jack
that would be the ultimate just like
sorry jack yeah you know what i really
like this one
hey you know what you want to rent it
here we go you didn't want to do that
though if given the opportunity you
wouldn't even want to
i would i would rent to you would you
really yes what because that's
guaranteed because i know you'll
yeah jack i will send you the deals
thank you
that's what you think for the record you
think it's better for jack in this
situation given given the entire context
to buy a house than to spend like 1200
bucks a month for rent and have the
mobility
to be able to move around and shift
around knowing that his income
is going up dramatically i get that you
know flexibility is
kind of what you're placing the value on
you know at the end of the day right
let's get real the 1200 versus the 2400
is nothing in the grand scheme of like
if we're talking he's going to be making
a lot of money
okay so it really comes down to the
flexibility it you know if the market
tanks he's stuck with this house
so you always got to look at every house
from every lens of
you know possibilities and so whenever
we buy a house we're like okay if we
flip this
let's say we make 20k that's cool um if
we wholesale it we might only make
5k whatever if we rent it we're going to
cash flow
x and we always think okay
we're going to go down the flipping
route but if the flipping route does go
bad
at least we know we can keep it and rent
it for this
and a lot of my rentals here in vegas
were flips that didn't pan out for
whatever reason
um and you know i end up keeping them
now they're good
i actually just filmed a video i was
telling you about this um
we put a pool in one of my summerlin
houses out here
luxury house i did not want a luxury
rental this house is worth like 900
grand
and um we we tried to flip it
and it just didn't work out because it
didn't have a pool i was stupid i was
like i made a big mistake of thinking oh
people are going to buy this without a
pool
but they don't at that type of price
point and
so i ended up having to rent it and uh i
told the tenant i said hey i'm going to
build a pool so that
by the time i do go to sell this ever
again i'll be able to
get what i'm supposed to get and long
story short that rental is
really good now because i bought it two
years ago
and even though it was a failed flip you
know the market's gone crazy right
i bought the house for 5.25 it's worth
900.
and it rents for 5700 a month
and my mortgage is three grand why
didn't you build the pool
just too costly yeah you know when i
looked at it
there was not a lot of comps in the
neighborhood and
there were some without pools but they
were on the golf course
and so it was like okay how do i factor
that in
none of the houses had the level of
finishes we had either they were all
just
you know normal house stock builder
stuff
so i'm like we're fully renovating it i
think we're going to still get good
money without a pool
and it just wasn't the case because the
pool was going to cost me an extra 50-60
grand
and it was a mistake and i ended up you
know keeping it thankfully though it's
going to end up working
out well for me what are you finding
right now for the rental market
dude it's just like the housing market
or you know the resale market it's
insane
people are like bidding up rentals and
it's nuts so you're mentioning earlier
they haven't caught up to
housing prices yet why is that just
because
um it's just kind of how it always go i
mean at least when
prices are moving so fast i mean
people's leases aren't up you know for
a year or whatever and a lot of and the
thing with rentals too is a lot of
people
renew their lease they don't even get
those rent increases right i've heard
you talk about that you don't even raise
your rents right
so that's kind of why part of the reason
versus when you go to sell a house
you're selling it for top dollar correct
you know so there's a different
philosophy and why
you know just we have to set new comps
and so that 5700 that i just set
is like a brand new rental comp the
highest before was five
grand so now i've set a new comp
somebody else will see that and they're
gonna
try and go for that and over time it'll
it'll do that
but there's just like less i don't know
why it is it's just
it always lags so las vegas
my understanding is is like an extreme
example of the whole housing market
across the you know the united states
right now where everything's like super
hot inventory is low and stuff like that
do you think that las vegas is more
extreme
because like of just the the all these
people moving out of their you know
california stuff like that
just to las vegas yeah um
i think vegas for the reasons you guys
moved here is
appealing to many people like you said
to californians
man you can get a mansion in vegas yeah
you guys look at this and you're like oh
you know 1.5 like
i don't even like that's that's already
a deal we don't even need to negotiate
like let's go
pay one six seriously but but i
you know as a guy who's lived here my
whole life look at it i'm like
ah you know i've seen it when it was you
know
700 and i'm like dang that goes for one
five now so it's different perspectives
but i think you're getting a lot of
people that are moving here
for cali for taxes for affordability
um you know vegas is a fun town too it's
not like
it's just boring and people are living
here for just
only money reasons like it's it's gotta
appeal that way
and i think you're gonna see um
a lot of big companies probably move
here for
the tax reasons the affordability
reasons and it's gonna just continue to
grow i mean that's what i think
i would love that i think from a
company's perspective it seems like they
really prefer to be in the middle of the
country
yeah and that's why i think like dallas
austin anywhere in texas
pretty central so if you want to go to
the east coast you can you want to go in
california
it's equal distance that's my only
thought with with nevada is that
even though they're really business
friendly and they're trying to bring
business here
it's just location-wise there's not a
lot of direct flights to you know a lot
of these other parts like there are in
dallas texas is the best i mean that's
it is what it is it's got its location
it's
business friendly it's it's huge you
know they can keep growing and growing
so
texas for sure is going to be number one
yeah you know but
there are people who don't want to live
in texas you know the californians want
to still
be able to go back to california yeah
same reason why you're here right
oh jack after everything we've talked
about now are you gonna buy a house what
do you think
i mean i've been leaning on buying a
house for a while now that's just
that sounds good to me i i think it just
makes more sense for my financial
situation to be paying into my own
equity i can make a mistake and still be
okay
you know and that's why i figure it'd be
fine for me to take the risk of buying a
home instead of just renting an
apartment or something like that because
i can
my risk tolerance is higher than average
for my age you know well and think about
this jack
if okay assuming that you get a mortgage
that
um you can still rent and you know break
even
right you're going to keep this house
for the long haul and it's going to
become part of your rental portfolio
even if you know the market goes down
right if you look back at 2000
the people that bought in 2005 um their
houses are worth more today than it was
in 2005. like it's
it's it's gone back up even after if
they could have withstood
the crash they'd be in a better spot
today because
not only is their house worth more but
they paid down 16 years of of principal
and now they're deep into that loan and
that loan is now amortizing paying off
more and more principal versus the
person who just buys today and
is paying all interest so i think
as long as you know what you do you can
withstand
you know an issue you know because
you've we're saying that you're going to
have
a lot more success here in the coming
years well i never said that that's what
graham said i believe i do
i believe in you man yeah i believe in
it thank you so
i think either way you're not you're
gonna be fine
like you're you're in the best position
i've seen a 22 year old in yeah you know
yeah no either way you can't go wrong if
you rent
you can't go wrong if you buy you can't
go wrong that's kind of what i figured i
can afford a mistake right now worst
case scenario i can i can afford it like
dogecoin
dogecoin like not selling ditch great
and uh
yeah so not to change the subject or
anything but you also bought into omi
oh my gosh you want to talk a little bit
about that yeah so
man that one that one gives me hurt
feelings i actually have a youtube
coming out about it
um so i'm not above
the pump and dump if i if i think people
are gonna pump it like we're just
talking about
dogecoin i'm like i'll i'll jump in on
it with no diamond hands
and um omi was one of those things just
like every influencer was like talking
about it and
logan paul's talking about it and you
know i should have known when vegas dave
was talking about it was probably not
a good thing to do but um anyways i'm
like i'll just buy in
and i bought 200 grand worth and uh
you know i ended up not selling it when
i should have
because i thought oh man this is gonna
like 2x or something everyone's hyping
it up
and eventually you know it goes live on
uni swap
logan paul shouts it out and it gets to
like you know
what was it 1.3 cents or something and
i'm up like 80 grand this was in like a
day or two
i'm like okay like we're headed to the
moon like we're gonna go up and
eventually all the whales saw that too
and they they started dumping
and then it dropped down to like nine
point nine cents and then like point
seven cents i'm like oh my gosh like
this is so dumb
and i didn't realize that um
man like to sell it was the biggest
hassle in the world because like to sell
it on uni swap you had to wrap it
you had to what does that mean to wrap
it i looked into that i did not
understand a single thing about it
at all i didn't understand it either but
i had to do it because i'm like i have
to liquidate this stuff and so
wait so what does it unwrap what does
that mean so
don't take this is like for sure advice
you guys can
correct us in the comments but um
essentially
it's on like go chain and that's what
you were asking me for if i could send
you go
and you have to get it on the ethereum
chain and so the only way to get it on
the ethereum chain is to wrap
it somehow with ethereum and um
then you can sell it on the ethereum
chain and on uni swap and so
that's what i did but the thing that i
learned from that whole experience was
um you know number one if people are
gonna pump it don't miss the pump
you know and then number two uh
know how to sell it beforehand because
if i knew how to sell it beforehand on
that day i would have made
80 grand um but three
um omi was very illiquid so what was
happening was
my 200 grand should not have moved the
price the way it was moving it
and so when i went to go sell it it
finally reached back to 0.9
um and i went to you know on uni swap
hey sell 200.
it would have dropped the price like 15
percent just me selling
200 grand and i was like what
like oh that's you know that's insane
yeah
that's 30 grand that i'll lose by
selling my own coin like i'm taking it
and so i had to sell it off in chunks i
had to sell it in 50 grand chunks
throughout like the next couple of days
so i didn't tank the price wow and uh
even still
at the 50 grand chunks it's called
slippage and
it dropped it by like five percent each
time
and wow oh my god yeah and like 200
grand is not
it should not do anything is that just
because the volume was so low yeah
there's just not enough liquidity
on uni swap and so i learned a i'm glad
i went through the experience because i
learned a ton about it and it's not to
say that omi's not legit
and their nft stuff is gonna like i
don't know but that wasn't the purpose
for me buying it yeah
i was just trying to make a quick buck
and uh i ended up losing
like 20 grand that could have been way
worse it could have been way worse
i was a cheap lesson well right now i
think it's trading in
like 60s 60. so if i would sell today i
would have lost
100 grand yeah so i am glad i i
liquidated yeah
i got uh caught up in the coin the coin
base
a little bit i i was watching that uh
meet kevin live stream
we i think we're all watching it waiting
for coinbase to to go public i had my
order ready
got uh i i got in most of my order i got
an 80 shares at
391 and then immediately the rest of my
shares didn't even execute i was like oh
crap i missed it i miss it and then i'm
watching the price go up
and uh then jack buys in
[Laughter]
it was just we watched to go to like 4
20 something
and instantly i was like wow i'm up a
few percent in like you know
a few minutes this is crazy and then it
starts drop and drop and dropping
370 comes around like okay i'm gonna buy
the tip
yeah bought bought a bit of the dip kept
dropping and then at the end of the day
or maybe it was the next day i bought
more like 3
30 something that's good but uh yeah
got uh got caught up in that hype yeah
dude the hype
the hype is good as long as you sell at
the hype you know you know what the
crazy thing is i i've
i've realized that if everyone thinks
something is gonna happen it's not gonna
happen if everyone thinks
gonna buy in it's gonna go to this price
it's not gonna happen
yeah one thing i've been experimenting
with crypto is
um i you know i own mainly just bitcoin
ethereum
but uh i learned a lesson from the omi
fail
but like i said i'm not opposed to
buying alts if like
i have good information that i trust but
but the one thing is like you said if
everyone's talking about it
don't do it um but i just bought an alt
you'll get a kick out of this called
like
pancake bunny it's paying like 365
return to um stake it
what the wait to stake it yeah what does
steak mean once again i'm not the super
crypto expert
it's like they loan it out for people
for leverage and collateralized
yeah loans what wait so how much is this
i put a hundred thousand into it why
when and you're making how much as of
right now
it's 365 percent a year
yeah that's got to be a pawn wait you
already know where this wait how much
you put in
i put a hundred thousand look and yeah
but you're already up six yeah well
there's a screenshot
it's up 12 now that's guy that sounds
like a ponzi
there's no way so who is paying that
dude
people okay so it's the same reason that
blockfy is able to
give crazy interest rates on bitcoin in
a theory
i would call but you know what that's
six you know who they're sending those
loans out to
right who block lie it's probably some
pretty sketchy entities
because those are the people that
actually use bitcoin as payment no but
but the thing is all there are so many
altcoins that are legit
making you know half a percent to one
percent a day
but it's not like it's not in the long
run it's not like hey we're guaranteeing
you this for the next
it's like this week this is what it's
paying
next week it's going to be totally
different i don't believe it
i mean i believe you're getting it i
believe you're getting it i don't
believe that that
is a legitimate it's risky because
here's the thing if
if any investment pays even 50 percent a
year
yeah every billionaire out there every
hedge fund manager every warren buffett
is going to go in on that well but they
can't it's against their
yeah the hedge fund they cannot do it
the creator themselves it's gonna be
listen if i had an investment that was
making fifty percent a year
every year i would not tell a soul i
would i would plow all my money in that
and maybe like tell hey hey mom dad hey
get your money in this and let me tell
you this like
why would i share that right so with
bunny nobody is talking about it
nobody's ever heard of it
sounds silly well by the time this comes
out i might already be out of it
you know what i'm saying yes so like but
the only reason i know about this
is because i i know a lot of crypto
traders
that like do millions and millions and
this is all they do they day trade
crypto like on these
random alt coins that are just paying
ridiculous sums of money at that time
and i finally got like so one of my
friends i finally was like hey
can you start doing this for me like i'm
willing to trade like i've watched you
guys make
millions doing this stuff and i don't
have the time i don't have the knowledge
but like stake me in it like let me get
in on it and so
i have no idea what bunny does i don't
know anything about it
um it sounds really dumb but
i'm willing to bet on it did you know
anything about homie yeah i knew more
about omi than i know about bunny
silly we're talking about bunny bunny i
mean
i don't know i i think it's called
pancake bunny pancake
does that make it better it sounds to me
like they're paying you
off with someone else's deposit
and then as people you know i'm not
saying you're doing this but as we're
talking about it then other people pile
in
and they make their money and they tell
other people to make their money well
that was the whole thing with homies
that was what i assumed was happening
with omi right like everyone's selling
oh me
through all these like different people
and
you know the ideas to pump it and all
these influencers talking about it like
omi was the example of what that was
versus
bunny which nobody even knows what it is
skeptical
just skeptical about it well i mean
there's definitely some nefarious stuff
going on with it
no way the sec is not looking at bunny
come on no buddy pay 150 a year
well here's the truth well so it's not
pancake bunny that's doing it it's the
the exchange is lending it because the
exchange needs
they need more bunnies pancake bunnies
out to other people
supply and demand but um people are
watching this just scratching their
heads
pancake bunny
this is my opinion on all this is my
opinion on all the alts
they're all rigged that's my opinion
even the big ones
and pancake bunny is one of them but a
hundred grand
ryan did you not question the name man
who's behind it no idea i want to get
the guy a pancake bunny we got to get
him on the podcast
you should get pancake bunny on but
let's hope
you know get some dudes taking off the
freeway
under the uh underpass the other night
we saw some dudes like token up i bet
that's one of the greats
dude i don't know all these altcoins man
i think like i said they're they're all
sketch i think they're all just
get rich quick schemes and like
there i think there are some legit ones
like at the top but
anything like past 100 to me is like
just they're all pumping into happening
i know i guess my limit for something
like that would be like 500 bucks
i would throw 500 bucks in pancake bunny
it just
it's just for you should do it pancake
money i don't know how to buy it how do
you buy it i don't know my friend bought
it for me
so you got to swap it and unwrap
it right here but here's the deal graham
so the only reason
i'm buying that is because i trust my
friend
that's it it has nothing to do with me
like being this crypto expert or
freaking i believe in pancake bunny i
don't believe
he's saying yeah i believe and fair i
believe in my friend
okay like if you told me like to do
something that i would be like all right
and that that's just how i feel about it
if he's investing you know hundreds of
thousands into it
of his own money then i believe in it
too
i think where i'm coming from lately i
think uh i've always been very risk
adverse
i hate risk i always like every every
real estate deal i went into
i felt so sure that i was going to make
money i was like
99.9 i'm in the profit from day one
i know what i'm gonna get on rent i
underestimate everything
so that you know even the worst case
scenario for me has always been like oh
yes you know i made money on that
so i've always come from that
perspective that i would rather
make a little bit and not maybe make a
ton
with the the really the peace of mind
that i'm not gonna lose
i just i don't like losing money so let
me give you the
the alternative pro risk guys point of
view on that yeah
so i had this conversation with my ceo
at our house flipping company
because he was very much like you he's
like i don't want to lose the company
money like
you know that's not good you're going to
get mad at me whatever fire me
who knows and i'm like dude by being too
conservative you're losing us money
because we're missing out on all these
opportunities
you know and so if you just take for
example let's just say we we looked at
10 houses right
and um i would have bought all 10 you
know i'm willing to live with the risk
on some of them
others are home runs we know they're
going to be good right and
let's just say those 10 houses make
30 or those 10 houses make 300 grand and
then you know
but in those 10 there were three that
lost but the other seven
still carried it and we made 300 grand
but if he was just
you know super risk-averse and we only
bought three houses and we made a
hundred grand like
i'm fine taking the losses to get the
overall gain
i don't know i feel like there's always
a balance of risk in that and that even
though you might be
getting a higher return you are taking a
higher risk i'm just saying instead of
because because it's always like a
teeter-totter a little bit i prefer to
take more on the side of okay i'm going
to de-risk a little
bit i'm sure i'm going to get less
profit over here but it's you know it's
going to be less risky
yeah it's always been my go-to and sure
and and then
as far as the extra profit sure could
have made more money
uh taking more risk but it's like
what would that extra money do you know
i i'm not going and doing that you were
telling me about the crazy date nights
and just throwing oh there's 200 bucks a
person
200 a person that that's 10
all-you-can-eat sushis
super sushi 10 of them we could all go
we could all go
to all-you-can-eat sushi yeah the price
of one plate
and i'd have money left over for the
thai iced tea which is unlimited by the
way four dollars and ninety-five cents
super stupid
but you i mean i think we had this
conversation on the first podcast
at the end of the day though like for us
we know we can make money like i have no
doubt that
you're gonna in the next five years make
so much money that
spending 200 bucks on a meal is not
going to matter
and so even for me like i like to spend
money on experiences so like last night
for my birthday right like
we rent out the the place and you know
we have
all that food and stuff like it wasn't
cheap how much was that my guess is
my guess was i guessed a hundred dollars
a person i guessed five
five thousand in total yeah that's what
i said yeah it was about five grand cool
yeah but like totally worth it to me
like to have an experience a hundred
bucks a person
um you know and have every friends
family they're like
well spent and uh it's
you're just like you're gonna remember
that forever versus if i don't do it and
i save the 5
000 like i wouldn't want to do that that
hits home
but see or you could do what uh what i
did for the uh what was it for one of
the housewarming parties
had people over at the house we got
pizza got some drinks i think under a
hundred bucks
we entertained uh like was it 10
people 12 people something like that
yeah i mean and there's nothing wrong
with dollars a person
well we do that too it's not like
everything is just
hey we got to go all you know like
there's a place for that and then
there's a place to
really go out i mean it's my birthday
right so that's only once a year yeah
i could spend a little bit yeah so oh we
should have charged a cover at the door
so like everyone who comes in like alex
is taking chickens
they have to buy a ticket right but
graham you know that was a business
expense
yeah you know that five grand is a
write-off uh
they just did the thing like you can
write off 100 of meals now
um and guess what
over at least what was it 75 percent of
those people are business
associates did that pass yep yeah it
really was yeah just
like last week was it last week last or
this week yeah i saw
it's crazy and then there's there's no
everything
how did i miss that what did it pass in
you can write off a hundred percent of
me i know what
what what bill was that under that that
can't just be a standalone bill no i
just saw like news articles and stuff
about it
yeah i talked to you about it didn't i
alex yeah
yeah and that's not a proposal in in a
package no
it was passed yeah all right yeah so
it's a good write-off
it was a great experience yeah and uh i
i think i air more on ryan's side
when it comes to this type of stuff i
think experience is like money is a
means to an end
you know it's not the end yeah like what
are you gonna use the money for like at
the end of the day
and if you do use it why not use it when
you're 30 and young and lively and
stupid
my only counter to that is that from
from my perspective you can get 95
of the same experience for 10 of the
cost you're not getting 95
of that experience eating pizza that was
a pretty crate yeah that was
that was a crazy night like good pizza
it wasn't just pizza gary brought
spring rolls that's true this video was
really really good
and we had two friends ver sent us
donuts
yeah it was uh it was nice it's not to
compare the nights they were both great
nights
right right no and like i said i i would
prefer to have
both of those types of nights you know
have the pizza nights have but then you
know have a really big night every so
often
let's get back on the subject of real
estate okay where do you see the market
heading over the next few years
in both las vegas and then in the bigger
picture as far as like interest rates
inflation the economy what you're seeing
with the jobs market here
yeah i mean as i was kind of saying with
jack i think
in two years from now um when we're kind
of looking at his time frame of
potentially wanting to move again
i i do think that this continues to go
up um
there's nothing currently right now in
april that says it's not
you know and until i see otherwise where
people are like
you know the government says we're
raising rates things are getting out of
control
we're not doing any more stimulus we're
i don't i just don't see that happening
anytime soon so
in vegas i think it's still gonna be
just crazy
i think californians are still moving
here i think
you know people from everywhere are
going to move here um
and i don't know it's hard to predict i
mean look
it's hard to predict any investment like
with certainty
i mean we'd all be super rich if we did
but
i i'm very confident that you know
it's not gonna go any time soon like the
only real risk right now
is the whole foreclosure and forbearance
thing you know that's what people have
been saying
for a year that's funny enough i don't
think there's any risk in that
i don't either yeah and people are like
oh man you know back
this time last year there's gonna be a
wave and i'm like no they ain't
foreclosing on people like
they're gonna they're gonna do
everything possible because it was the
government's fault like they shut people
down so
these people don't deserve to get
foreclosed on and so
a year from now you know here we are
nobody's still getting foreclosed on
and that's honestly causing a big part
of why there's no
inventory because those houses would
have been potential inventory people
that had to sell
that are now not doing it because they
don't have to and so
um i don't see them changing that
anytime soon either i think they're
gonna
do loan modifications they're gonna do
everything to keep those people in the
home
i heard a pretty interesting point i
think this was during millennial money
but someone brought up
the fact that like maybe the government
won't let another recession happen
after like this whole like pumping all
this money into the economy and stuff
like that and keeping rates low
do you think that the government would
let another like not 2008 but like
another recession or something happen to
that degree
i mean i think they're doing everything
possible to not let it happen
um man there was a really good book
um i forgot what it's called but
basically this guy predicted this like
years ago he said essentially the
government was going to have to start
printing
a ton of money to keep up with all the
technological advances and
all this stuff because tech is making
things cheaper
and the government always wants to
promote
like the right amount of inflation you
know we don't want hyper we don't want
deflation because then people don't
spend money
we want to have the right amount but his
his thesis was
in order for us to maintain that level
of inflation they're gonna have to pump
crazy amounts of money and we're seeing
that you know we're seeing more money
printed than ever
and it was cool to like read it and look
and see like man
he called it and um the
the theory is that it's going to keep
happening there's just no way
to to keep things going unless they
continue to print money
and i mean they're going to do
everything they can i mean they've
already proven that they'll just keep
pumping they'll keep dropping rates
if things the moment things start to go
south
they just use every tool they have are
you in bitcoin at all
yeah um yeah i've got 860 right now on
this
wow let me see this geez you're beating
andre on this
and i just got a wow i bought more on
coinbase
are you near a million yet yeah if you
count if you count pancake bunny i am
great answer wow before you're almost 50
50 between bitcoin and ethereum
yeah was that on purpose or just by
chance that the ethereum goes
just been going up more okay how much
that is principal
um on that 500. oh my gosh and i bought
it in
january and february wow oh my god
fantastic
yeah well done that's yeah that's why
i'm playing with house money on on
yeah so i i dude and part of that book
too
i i'll you'll have to link to it once uh
i tell you once i find it but um
part of it was him predicting bitcoin
also
was gonna rise because of this like he
was like
bitcoin is he's like it's pretty much
the way that it's gonna happen
how long ago was that book written like
three years ago
yeah and it was after bitcoin tanked you
know like it was in between this period
where everyone
thinks bitcoin is trash right he's like
no bitcoins
um oh it's called the price of tomorrow
by jeff booth so to circle back to real
estate um because you're the expert here
uh what would you say are the things
that you should really really look out
for
as a first-time homebuyer the biggest
nightmares those kinds of things
hmm you know i think always get a home
inspection
you just don't know what's going on with
the house if you're new um
you know don't trust what your eyes tell
you get an inspector i think that's a
good way to prevent a lot of that
um another thing i would say is
you know really make sure you have all
your contingencies built into the
contract
have your due diligence have your
appraisal contingency
um because a lot of these a lot of these
agents right now are gonna try and get
you to waive that they're gonna be like
hey
wave your due diligence period buy it as
is wave your
appraisal contingency you know if it
doesn't appraise you're on the hook
and uh i think in a market like today
where things
um may not appraise if you don't have
the money to cover the difference
um you're gonna probably either lose
your earnest money deposit
or you know be out of a lot of cash to
buy that house so
i think paperwork wise just make sure
you're doing it right a good
realtor should you know understand those
things um
but you know as far as the houses and
everything like that
um i would say if you're a first time
home buyer
i said this multiple times like i just
put as little down as possible cash-wise
um don't wait to save up 20
like that's just my opinions how i got
started and
you know i think leverage is the
greatest asset that real estate
you know gives you and so if somebody
can give me 97
and i only have to come up with three
like to me that's
what makes real estate so great when you
mentioned
inspections what i've always done
because i have been
uh advising clients in the past to waive
that appraisal to waive that loan and to
waive the
inspection and it works really well yep
uh so what i've done instead
is for the inspection as soon as they
see the house as soon as they know they
want to write an offer
we get an inspection done ahead of time
so that by the time they write an offer
they know exactly what they're walking
into
they know all the issues and then
they're able to go and write that offer
without the inspection contingency
uh and then as far as the loan usually
what i've done
is uh get the assurance from and they
have to be a
really good buyer in certain uh
situations where you know
a hundred percent they're getting a loan
it's just they got to go through the
underwriting process but
uh in those specific situations it's
worth it at least
in those for those clients to waive it
all
go in they know exactly what they're
walking into and the seller gets that
peace of mind that they know they have a
done deal
yeah no i agree oh and then and then
here's here's their out by the way
when the seller has to give their seller
property questionnaire transfer
disclosure statement
they could just say oh no i don't like
that uh you all right now i'm gonna back
out from that now they could always
argue that like okay no you owe us but
i've never had that situation ever
happen before and that usually gives the
buyer like a five
sometimes i will say a three to seven
day window where they could still back
out
if something were to happen yeah you can
do that with the hoa package too
yeah oh that's a good one so and because
that takes
a lot of time to order that yeah so that
they're look there's a lot of ways to
get out of a contract we've gotten out
of contracts many of times
um but i guess my point with it is that
if you're a first-time buyer you've
never
you don't know anything like make sure
you understand
how you could potentially lose your
earnest money deposit but
you know if we waive everything on all
of our deals
because we know our number like yeah
we're buying this yep how did you learn
so much about real estate and what
resources do you think someone like me
or someone else out there that may not
know so much about real estate can
educate themselves to be
you know as smart as they can and make
the best you know investments in real
estate as possible
you know when i first started out i was
just reading books and listening to
podcasts
so i used to listen to the bigger
pockets podcast um i've been on there a
couple times and
want to you know love brandon and those
guys really good guys
um and that was like it when i was
starting because they were like the
only ones at that time you know they
started back in like
12 or 13 or something and i didn't watch
youtube
in fact i didn't watch youtube until
like last year um
so i think there's a lot of great free
resources
but the one thing that really took me to
the next level
was by starting to just pay for
mentorship
get because i never had a mentor like i
just had to learn by myself and figure
it out
but the moment i started hiring people
to like train me on what they already
did
things changed you know i did that i
showed you my org chart at the office
right like i didn't invent that org
chart you know like i didn't come up
with it like a guy
a consultant helped us build it and do
that and it's drastically changed our
business so
um i think having that type of stuff is
super huge
um i've got an education company as well
called future flipper
you know we've got courses coaching
products
you know all that stuff to help people
start out um and we get people every day
who get their very first deal
um well i i don't wanna say every day
but we see it every week
people posting about getting their first
deals and we're not just talking like
people
buying a house to live in like we're
talking about flips that are discounted
and
you know getting good deals and that's
is that like nationwide
yeah yeah we have man i got like these
students in
hawaii all the way to new jersey um
i had a workshop in my office this week
on thursday
and i had one guy who came all the way
from new jersey
um just to learn i had another um
two kids that were 18 years old in high
school
you know coming to learn to flip houses
i was like man
like these guys are hungry like but
they're doing it right because
if you know what you want to do you're
18 years old like just go learn
from the best possible guy you can learn
and learn it at 18.
like if i would have learned it at 18 oh
my gosh things would be different like
if graham if you knew what you knew now
at
18 it'd be way different but i just
i never like was able to build those
relationships and find good mentors i
just didn't know how
so what exactly does the future flipper
program offer like
what is what's the main advantage of
being a student um
i mean we talked earlier about the off
market stuff um
most people will never learn to do any
of the off-market stuff that we talked
about
um because there's a lot that goes into
it like i said with
you know your budgets your marketing
channel you know your sales skills for
closing deals getting creative to do
like deals like that seller finance we
did for the apartment
you know that type of stuff is is what
we really preach
but um at the end of the day what the
biggest thing we
we really try to hammer home is if you
can find good deals
you can do whatever you want in real
estate i mean if you find a good deal
you could flip it you can make money you
could wholesale it if you don't want to
go through the construction all that
stuff or you can keep it as a rental and
build a portfolio but it all comes back
down to
how good are you at finding good deals
and then on top of that
you know can you raise money to buy all
these deals can you
you know do construction on the deals
you buy you know because
it's cool when you're doing one and you
know you can do it all but as you start
to do more and more
you got to start getting more people to
help you fund the deals
like graham's doing for you um you got
to get more contractors
because you know we all know
construction is tough and in a lot of
places
and you know at the end of the day
finding deals though it all comes back
down to finding deals so
that's what we really teach that seems
like like as someone who isn't really in
real estate that seems like the most
complicated
of all things and just like the uh the
the cumbersome task of
of finding deals is like it's uh
it makes it scary to like get your toes
wet you know what i mean it was hard for
me too
i would spend six months trying to find
a deal
writing offers having to go over the
price i was comfortable paying
losing out and even sometimes i would
have an offer accepted
go through inspections find issues
couldn't i wasn't able to negotiate a
price that i felt was fair for that
so yeah and that was me looking every
single day as a real estate agent for a
deal for myself
yeah it took a long time well that's the
thing too is we're talking about it in
the competitive market today like
man that was back then imagine now
trying to find deals
as a realtor on the market that you know
you could flip or wholesale i mean
our students still do it you know there
are markets that are not vegas you know
and they're not as competitive and they
they can get deals but
um you know for me anyways the off
market side of things is where
it doesn't matter what's going on you
can get deals no matter what because now
you're going direct to the sellers
your your understanding you know all the
things that happen with that
so i think if you can develop the skill
to to go off market which is very time
consuming like you said
but um it allows you to get deals when
no matter what's going on how about this
man we'll link to your information down
below in the description so for anybody
who wants to check that out it's down
there
sweet man there you go thank you for
coming on yeah we owe you so much for
doing this man
yeah it's always good hanging out with
you the day after your birthday
you're out late came here the next day
hey right on time we gotta do what we
gotta do appreciate it man thank you so
much hey good seeing you guys again cool
thanks for hooking up jack by the way
thank you i'm i'm so excited actually
we're gonna keep in touch
no what we're gonna do is we're going to
wholesale you a house
and then we'll do another podcast about
it once you buy that house
this will be a recurring topic on the
podcast so i'll keep you guys all
updated on my real estate journey
yeah you're also going to invest in
pancake bunny yes don't know
nobody else buy me like don't do it
pancake bonnie jeez
all right so with that said you guys
thank you so much for watching i really
appreciate it as always make sure to
destroy the like button
the subscribe button and notification
bell oh you got to say you got to look
them in the in the eye
tell them smash like button make sure
you guys smash the like button
no destroy it oh don't just smash the
like button you gotta destroy it there
we go and also get your free stock down
below in the description public is going
to give you a free stock worth all the
way up to 50
plus i'm posting all my stocks in there
so if you want to be a part of it use
that link down below
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time
iced coffee all right all right welcome
back to the 50th ever
ice cut